[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ملفات الخامسه من
العربيه والبدايه بابرز عناوينها
[موسيقى]
قصف صاروخيه روسيه استهدف مناطق عده
باوكرانيا
بالسودان وتنسيق لتقديم دعم اقتصادي كبير
للحكومه المدنيه
[موسيقى]
ونبقى في ايران دوما وسط اضرابات
الثوريه توعد المتظاهرين والمانيا تقول ان
تغيير شرطه الاخلاق لا يلبي مطالب
المحتاجين
ومن اخبار المونديال المثيره اليابان
تواجه كرواتيا ومباراه حزينه ما بين
البرازيل وكوريا الجنوبيه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا نبدا من اخر التطورات
الميدانيه باوكرانيا تحدث مسؤول
الاوكرانيه عن انفجارات في خرتيب جراء قصف
روسي بصور قروز وقالت مصادر اوكرانيه ان
قصف روسيا مكثفا على مناطق عده في البلاد
قد وقع مشيرتان الى انقطاع الكهرباء
والمياه في عده مدن بسبب القذف الروسي وقد
طلبت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه المواطنين
بالنزول الى الملائع بسبب القذف الروسي
وافادت رويترز بضرب صواريخ روسيه لمحطات
الطاقه في سوني شمال شرق اوكرانيا
وائل طلع على الاوضاع ميدانيا نبقى دوما
مع مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل من العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كياب مرحبا بك حذيفه نحن امام
انبا تشير الى غاره جويه مكثفه ضعنا في
الصوره
اكثر من 100 قذيفه صاروخيه تم اطلاقها نحو
الاراضي الاوكرانيه استهدفت عدد كبير جدا
من المدن الاوكرانيه من بينها العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كيف حتى الغرب الاوكراني مدينه
الفوز فينيسيا ايضا في الغرب الاوكراني في
الشرق هنالك خارطه
جميع هذه المدن تعرضت لعمليات قصف واسعه
طبعا الان مدينه سومي انقطع عنها التيار
الكهربائي تماما وكذلك المياه ايضا مدينه
تعيش الان في هذه اللحظات دون مياه كهرباء
تماما ايضا كذلك مدينه
في الحقيقه حتى هذه اللحظه نحن في وضع
الطوارئ
الان محطه المترو لا تعمل في العاصمه اكيد
وفي جميع المدن هذا طبعا
يبدو ان قلب العاصمه من خلفك تسيير الامور
بشكل طبيعي على عكس الاطراف على ما يبدو
نعم في الحقيقه فقط هذا يمكن ان نعزيه الى
ان المواطنين تعودوا على وضع الغارات وعلى
عمليات القصف يعني الان بشكل كبير
المواطنين لا يلقون بالا عندما يتم اطلاق
صافرات الانذار لا يذهبون الى الملاجيء
بشكل كبير لا يلتزمون بالنزول عندما يتم
اعلان ذلك من السلطات ولكن هذا يؤدي الى
حالات من الوفيات طبعا هنالك بعض الحالات
في وسط المدينه في القصف الذي تم في ثالث
العشرين من اكتوبر توفي عدد كبير من الناس
الذين فقط قالوا على الطريق او كانوا في
سياراتهم قتلوا جراء همم سقوط الصواريخ في
مركز مدينه تكييف هذا امر فقط الناس
اعتادت عليه ولكن الامر خطير طبعا كما
تعلمين الرشا اللي همم بشكل كبير الان
الدوله همم يعني همم نظره الاوكرانيه
جميعها تعيش في حاله الانذار الجوي
الجبهات القتال نفسها اليوم تم قصف بشكل
كبير جدا خاصه في لوغاز
وفيونيسكو لعمليات قسم واسعه اكثر من 40
فا اطلقت فقط على اخرصون هذا خلاف ال 100
القديفه صاروخيه التي اطلقت والسادفت
محطات الطاقه رشا شكرا لك يا زميلي حذيفه
عادل نص العربيه من كيف على هذه المعلومات
وفي تطور جديد ولافت افاد تقارير اعلاميه
اسرائيليه بان موسكو طلبت تل ابيب بعدم
عرقله نقل منظومات الدفاع جوي روسيه من
سوريا لاستخدامها بجبهات القتال باوكرانيا
وذلك وسط تقارير غربيه عن نقص في مخازن
السلاح الروسيه
عمليه تفكيك بدات بها روسيا في اغسطس
الماضي لمنظومه اس 3 في سوريا التقطتها
الاقمار الصناعيه لتعلن وكاله ايميجسات
انترناشونال الاسرائيليه انا روسيا تنقل
بطاريه المنظومه الى البحر الاسود وتدور
التوقعات حول نقل المنظومه بالكامل
لاستخدامها في الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
توقعاتهم تصيب على ما يبدو اليوم تطلب
روسيا من اسرائيل عدم عرقله نقلها لمنظمات
الدفاع الجوي من قواعدها العسكريه في
سوريا الى اوكرانيا
مع المعلومات الاستخباراتيه الغربيه حول
انخفاض مخزون روسيا من الاسلحه بعيده
المدى منها على وجه الخصوص مخمنه انها لا
تكفي الا لشهر واحد اخر تصريحات الغرب
كانت من قبل وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
والتي بينت ان الطلعات الجويه ده الروسيه
في اوكرانيا انخفضت بعد معلومات تفيد بان
لجوء روسيا للمسيرات الايرانيه هو نتيجه
العوز في الصواريخ البالستيه الروسيه
القتال في اوكرانيا يسير بوتيره منخفضه
ويشير الى ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد تكون
لها افاق اكثر اشراقه في الاشهر المقبله
ليست منظومه فقط التي يتم سحبها من سوريا
مصادر اكلت للعربيه انا الوجود الروسيه في
المناطق الداخليه والجنوبيه قد قل قل
واصبح مقتصرا على بعض الضباط الذين يقومون
بالاشراف على العمليات عدا عن انخفاض
وتيره الطلعات الجويه الروسيه في اشاره
الى السحب سلاح الجو الروسي من سوريا
روسيا التي تعتبر من اكبر الموردين للمواد
الخام لتصنيع السلاح بعد التلجئ الى
صواريخ كوريا الشماليه ومسيرات ايران لا
بل لاساليب اخرى كالهجمات السبرانيه على
البناء التحتيه الاوكرانيه التي لا يقل
تاثيرها عن الضربات الماديه بحسب مصادر
الغربيه الى عمر العربيه
مناطق في مدينه دونيسكو هي المدينه
الرئيسيه في اقليم دونتس العربيه يقول ان
قصفا يتم بهذه الصواريخ صواريخ جراند كانت
داخليه منضبه ايضا منذ قليل قالت انها
عطره على بقايا صاروخ في المنطقه الحدوديه
مع اوكرانيا نعود الى التقارير التي كانت
تشير بشكل واضح الا ان هناك مطالبات من
موسكو لاسرائيل بسماحي بعبوري انظمه
الدفاع صاروخيه من سوريا الى الاراضي
الاكرانيه ينضم الينا من موسكو الكاتب
السياسي البني مرحبا بك سيد بسام البعض
يعتقد بعد قراءه هذه التقارير ان القوه
الروسيه في وضع خارج للغايه لدرجه انها
تحاول اقناع اسرائيل بنقل انظمه الدفاع
الصاروخيه من سوريا
اسعد الله اوقاتكم اوقات مشاهدين قناه
العربيه لا ليست روسيا بوضع حرج وهي ليست
بحاجه لطلب اذن اسرائيل لانها عندما ادخلت
منظومه 300 اس 300 للدفاع الجوي لم تستاذن
اسرائيل حتى فكيف لها ان تستاذن اسرائيل
بموضوع خروجها يعني ان تم وفعلا قد نقلت
روسيا هذه المنظومه حسب الاقمار الصناعيه
للدفاع فهي منظومه دفاعيه هذا الامر الذي
يطحد موضوع نفاذ الاسلحه الهجوميه لان
السلاح الدفاعي مختلف كليا عن السلاح
الهجومي واكبر دليل على كلامي هو تقرير
حذيفه السيد مراسل قناه العربيه من
اوكرانيا الذي تحدث قبل تماما عن موضوع
استهداف روسيا لاوكرانيا بحجمه صاروخيه
وصلت الى 100 صاروخ منذ ساعات قليله يعني
هم يتحدثون عن 120 صاروخ اسكندر بقي في
الترسانه الروسيه وهذا الامر غير مطابق
للحقيقه على الاطلاق فقط
نشرت وسائل الاعلام الروسيه ان الصناعات
العسكريه الروسيه اليوم وصلت الى مرحله
تعادل ما كانت تقوم به الصناعات العسكريه
ايام الحرب الوطنيه العظمى او الحرب
العالميه الثانيه يعني هناك صناعات على
العسكريه تعمل على مدار الساعه من اجل
انتاج المقذوفات والزخائر والصواريخ
اعتقادي الحرب الاعلاميه والنفسيه ما بين
الجانبين ولكن دعني اسالك ايضا عن تصريحات
لوزير الدفاع الروسيه تقول انها ستلجا الى
استخدام اسلحه حديثه في اوكرانيا وسط
تقديرات ايضا تشير الى ان هناك ما يشبه
التراجع العسكري بهذه التقارير لروسيا في
اوكرانيا خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
يعني هذه التقارير كلها بناء على الحمل
الاعلاميه التي قلت لك انها تشن الغرب على
روسيا وهذه التقارير هي عباره عن تغطيه
لثلاث امور مهمه الامر الاول ان الغرب
بناء على تصريحات مسؤوليه ووسائل اعلاميه
يقول انه لديه نقص في المخزون الاستراتيجي
للذخائر وقد طلب من بعض دول الشرق
الاوسطيه تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ ناس ماسك
التي سيزود بها لاحقا هذه الدول التي
ستستغني عنها سالي سال الامر الاهم انهم
يريدون ان يغطوا على موضوع ان ااه احد
مسؤولين الامريكيين العسكريين طلب من
تركيا تسليم منظومه اس 400 لاوكرانيا
مقابل دخولها في عودتها الى مجال افهم 35
الطائرات الامريكيه
الامر الاخير في هذه النقاط المهمه انهم
يريدون ان يغطوا على كل
التقصير الذي يقوم به ايصال الاسلحه الى
الجبهه انا لا اثق بهذه التقارير الغربيه
بانه هناك نقص في الذخيره لديها ولكن يبدو
التعقيم في الموضوع انا الضربات صاروخيه
الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه ادت اكلها مما
ادى الى تعطيل لوجستيات توصيل هذه الاسلحه
او يريدون الضغط
الروسيه الاوكرانيه ولكن اقتصاديا بعد هذا
الفاصل
موسكو تجهز ردا على تحديد سعر سقف للنفط
الروسي وتؤكد انه لن يؤثر على تمويل
عمليتها باكرانيا
فيها شيء ميزها يا سيدي على لمه اهل
الحجاز لقمه منتهى على سفراتهم ولا الحمير
تحت غيوم الجنوب ووسط جبالها والله على
صحن جريش اجمعنا في نجد الاحباب وما تدري
تمدح اللمه ولا المجبوس ما نسمه هواء على
بحر الشرقيه
وبهارات ثري دي يا بعد حيي ماخذه من ريح
الهبوب الشماليه ولبن المراعي اطعام
المميز حاضر معنا فيكي جمعتنا الحلوه
بدانا بتموحي كبيرا لبناء عالم فعال
واليوم نركز على بناء المستقبل
[موسيقى]
والمرضى هذه
طاقه تغير العالم باكمله
هذه
لتوفير رحلات الطيران
[موسيقى]
تسمعها
قد لا يكون حقيقه يجب التسليم بها
فمهما بلغت اهميه الخبر
تاكيده او نفيوه يعتمد فقط على المصدر
كواليس وسائل الاعلام العربيه والعالميه
في التفاعل مع الاخبار على كل من الصوت
من المصدر الجمعه السابعه والنصف على شاشه
العربيه
ثقتكم ما جات اليوم
بنيناها معكم يوم بعد يوم
ين هذه التربيه الصح
في مزارع بالمعايير الاصح
الدجاج اليوم
[موسيقى]
مشوار
ومع هذا لسه بتعرف كيف تختار حليب المراعي
الطازج الفرق بين الامهات
الخامسه من العربيه مستمره معكم دخلت
اليوم اكبر حزمه من العقوبات الغربيه على
النفط الروسيه حيزه تنفيذ وذلك بتحديد سقف
لسعر الخام الروسي عند 60 دولارا للبرميل
الخطوه تهدف بحسب من اتخذها الى حرمان
موسكو من الايرادات التي تستخدمها لتمويل
عملياتها في اوكرانيا لكنك تقول انا تنفيذ
القرار على الارض يبدو صعبا الحاضر سيشمل
عمليات استيراد النفط المنقول بحرا
والمنتج في روسيا بما في ذلك خدمه التامين
والوساطه واصول النقل لكنه لن يطبق في حال
شراء النفط بسعر السقف المحدد عند 60
دولارا او اقل السعر المحدد يتم احتسابه
عند تحميل النفط الخام على متن السفينه
حيث لا يتضمن تكلفه النقل والرسوم في حين
انه لن يخضع ايضا لي النفط المكرر هذا
النفط المكرر لن يخضع للقرار وبدا تنفيذ
القرار فانه لن يسمح لشركات التامين
بتقديم خدماتها الا في حال شحن النفط
الخام تحت السقف المحدد الا ان وكاله
درومبيرج اشارت الى ان شركه انجوستراك
انسورانس الروسيه قد تكون احد خيارات
موسكو لتغطيه التامين ورغم ان تركيا
والهند تعترفاني بعقود التامين الروسيه
الا ان الصين لم تفعل ذلك حتى الان الحضر
يطبق فقط على شحنات الخام المنقوله بحرا
كما يستثني القرار بالغوريه اذا يمكنها
مواصله استيراد الخمر الروسي المنقول بحرا
حتى نهايه عام 2014
بالمقابل اكادت روسيا ان فرض الغرب حدا
اقصى لاسعار النفطها سيؤدي الى زعزعه
استقرار اسواق الطاقه العالميه ولكنه لن
يؤثر على قدرتها على مواصله ماتصفه
بعمليتها العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
فيما شدد المتحدث باسم الكريم ليندمث كوب
على ان روسيا تعد او تعد ردها على القرار
الذي اتخذته مجموعه السبع وحلفاءها مؤكده
ان روسيا والاقتصاد الروسيه لديهما القدره
المطلوبه لتلبيه احتياجاتهم متطلبات
العمليات العسكريه الخاصه بشكل كامل
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى ملف رئيسي في الخامسه من
العربيه ملف السودان فقد رحبت الخارجيه
السعوديه بتوقيع الاطراف السياسيه
السودانيه لاتفاق الايطاليه للانتقال
السياسي في البلاد واكدت الخارجيه
السعوديه انها ستواصل دعم السودان لحفظ
امنه واستقراره وبما يحققوا السلام
والنماء وجددت دعم المملكه الاليه
الثلاثيه في تسهيل الحوار والمباحثات بين
الاطراف المرحله الانتقاليه
واشنطن ايضا بدورها
للانتقال السياسي في السودان وقالت انها
تشكيله حكومه مدنيه في البلاد عاملا اساسي
لاستئناف المساعدات الدوليه واكدت واشنطن
انها تناسق مع الشركاء لتقديم دعم
اقتصاديا كبير للحكومه المدنيه للانتقاليه
في السودان
في غضون ذلك اعلن عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس
مجلس اسياده الانتقالي ان الاتفاق
الايطاليه الذي تم توقيعه يهدف الى انهاء
الصراع بين القوه المدنيه والعسكريه واكد
ان اهم الغايات هو تحويل الجيش الى مؤسسه
دستوريه ومنع تاسيسه وتحذيبه
لا تعني اتفاق مع طرف واحد او ما جهه
محدده
وانما هو توافق
وتراضي على قضايا وطنيه يجب ان يتم وضع
الحلول لها بمشاركه واسعه من القوه
المدنيه
واصحاب المصلحه بنيه الوصول لمخرجات تنهي
حاله الصراع والتشاكس القائم بين القوه
المدنيه
والقوه العسكريه حتى نهيظ الطريق الحقيقي
وانا واصل ملف السودان ولكن نشير فقط الى
هذا العاجل بوتين يزوروا جسر القرني في
اول زياره له بعد تفجير هذا الجسر في
اكتوبر الماضي نعود الى السودان مره اخرى
المتحدث باسم قوى الحوريه والتغيير قال
بدوره ان عنوان الاتفاق الايطالى السوداني
هو السعاده الحكم المدني وفق تعبيره
والعقد الاجتماعي الجديد
الساده والسيدات ان هذا ان هذا الاتفاق
الايطالي
عنوانه استعاده الحكم المدني الديمقراطي
واكمال مهام ثوره ديسمبر المجيده وغايته
توحيد بنات وابناء شعبنا تحت ظل مشروع
وطني غائم على الحريه والسلام والعداله
والمواطنه في اقامه سلطه مدنيه ديمقراطيه
تستكمل مهام
[موسيقى]
وانا صدم حضراتكم ردود الفعل داخل الشارع
السودانيه على هذا الاتفاق تنضم الينا
زميلتي لينا يعقوب مراسله العربيه من
الخرطوم مرحبا لينا كيف تبدو ردود الفعل
على هذا الاتفاق هل يشعر المواطن السوداني
انه امام مرحله جديده بالفعل بوقع هذا
الاتفاق
اهلا بك رشا ربما يتباين الشارع السوداني
في التعبير عن شعوره لهذا الاتفاق ربما
هناك متفائلون وهناك متشائمون وهناك
معارضون الان انا اقف معك في هذا المكان
ربما هذا واحد فقط من ردود الافعال صحيح
هناك فئه سعيده ولكن كما تسمعين هذه
القنابل الصوتيه ليست قنابل صوتيه فرحه
انما هي معارضه لهذا الاتفاق واستمرار
الشارع للتظاهر تجاه القصر الجمهوري رفضا
للتسويه والشراكه الجديده بين المدنيين
والعسكريين وليس كل المدنيين طبعا هناك
كثير من الاحزاب الرافده هذه تظاهرات رشا
كما تشاهدينها امامك انطلقت تجاه القصر
الجمهوري تطلق الشرطه الغاز المسير للدموع
على المتظاهرين الذين تفرقوا ربما الان في
موقف شرواني ولكن ما زالت محاوله ابعادهم
من هذا المكان والمحيط وموقف شروني وشارع
القصر مستمر حتى لحظه الامر
لنا الان تنتقلها لنا لنا يعقوب مراسله
العربيه من الخرطوم هناك ما يشبه الاحتجاج
وفقا لزميلتي لينا من قبل بعض العناصر في
السودان احتجاجا على هذا الاتفاق وبدا في
تسيير مسيرات الى القصر الجمهوري وفقا
لوصف زميله لنا يعقوب والام يرد باطلاق
همم قنابل الغاز المثير للدموع لذلك
تشاهدون هذه الصور في سماء العاصمه
الخرطوم اعود لك مره اخرى لنا هل هناك
اتضاح لهويه هذه العناصر التي ترفض هذا
الاتفاق الى اي اتجاه تنتمي
هي لجاره المقاومه اعلنت انها ترفض هذا
الاتفاق وموقفها معلن مسبقا انها تفض اي
اشتراك جديده بين المدنين
والتغيير الذي قبل بهذا الاتفاق طبعا هناك
جزء اخر او هناك شارع اخر رصدنا ربما ردود
افعاله امس بانه متفائل ان يحاول هذا
الاتفاق او ان يحققه يعني شكرا لكي لنا
على كل هذه المعلومات سنتابع هذا المشهد
بالطبع لنا يعقوب مراسله العربيه ونسف
لعدم وضوح الصوره والصوت بشكل جيد
هذا ورحم سفيره الاتحاد الاوروبي لدى
الخرطوم بتوقيع الاتفاق الايطالى بالسودان
وقال المتحدث انا الاتفاق يمثل خطوه مهمه
في طريق الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
فيه ان هذا الاتفاق عباره عن خطوه مهمه في
طريق الانتقال الديمقراطي في السودان
في الانضمام لهذه العمليه لكن لا يوجد
مكان للمخربين الاتحاد الاوروبي يداعم قوي
للاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد ونشكرهم على
تيسير هذه العمليه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم الاليه الثلاثيه
وسفير الاتحاد الافريقي في السودان محمد
بلعيش دعى المجتمع الدولي لدعم السودان
لكي يستطيع مواجهه تحديات المرحله القادمه
حتى تستطيع رفع هذه التحديات
ويعتبر الاتحاد الافريقي السوداني الجديد
اساسا في استقرار الفضائي الافريقي بشكل
عام
وفضاء القرن
الافريقي بشكل خاص وتحقيق طموحات شعوب
المنطقه في الاندماج والتنميه
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم المحلل السياسي
خالد عبد العزيز مرحبا بك سيد خالد اساس
هذا الخلاف لم يكن فقط ما بين المقاومه
العسكري والمكون المدني ولكن بين المكونات
المدنيه نفسها هل تستطيع هذه المكونات
السياسيه الان المدنيه ان تتجاوز خلافاتها
للمضي قدما في تطبيق هذا الاتفاق وانجاحه
كبيره ما بين المكونات المدنيه الغسامات
في الاهداف من حاله وجود اتفاق مع
العسكريين وعدم وجود مع اتفاق مع
العسكريين هناك اطراف تطالب بابعاد
العسكريين من المشهد تماما وتقديمهم
لمحاكمات هناك اطراف تؤمن بان هناك ضروره
سياسيه باحداث توازن وخلق نوع من العلاقه
بين السياسيين والمدنيين يؤسس لمرحله
جديده في السودان فلذلك هناك تباين كبير
في وجهه النظر حتى بين الاطراف المحسوبه
على القوه التابعه للثوره بين الاطراف
النظام القديم الذي يرفض الاتفاق تماما
ايضا انصار الرئيس السابق عمر البشير ايضا
يرفضون الاتفاق تمام لانه يهدد مصالحهم
واحدد وجود
السياسي وهو بالتاكيد هم عارضين لاي خطوات
ضدهم همم المطلوب بشكل كبير هو القوه
المدنيه الواقعه على الانتفاخ اليوم ان
تحاول ان توسع مظله الدفاع
اا يكون بداخله كل القوه السياسيه في
السودان التي تراهن على تحقيق التحول
الديمقراطي لديها مصلحه حقيقييه فان يكون
هناك تحول ديمقراطي في السودان وان تكون
هناك خطوات جديه لاكمال اا عمليه السلام
في السودان وان تكون هناك اطباق واحد
التقدم في المساله الاقتصاديه
بشكل كبير وفقا لبنوده الحكم المدني في
السودان وابعاد الجيش صح التعبير الى
سكناته العسكريه وهذه كانت الغايه هل
تتوافر اراده حقيقيه لدى المكونات التي
شاركت في هذا الاتفاق على انجحه بالفعل ام
انها قد تخزن الشعب السوداني ان صح
التعبير الذي يفكر فقط في الاستقرار
من اكبر الازمات هي هو ده عدم الثقه ما
بين الاطراف اذا كان ما بين المكون
العسكري والمكون الماده المترافقه الموقعه
او ما بداخل حتى المكونه العسكري هناك بعض
التباينات داخل المؤسسه العسكريه من
الموقف من الاتفاق من الموقف من التعامل
المشترك داخل هذه المؤسسه العسكريه
والامنيه
ولذلك مطلوب ان يكون هناك خطوات عمليه في
في في تنفيذ في في تقدم في الاتفاق حتى
يتم اعاده بناء صيغه ما بين الاطراف لانه
بدون توفر حاله من الصيغه بين الاطراف
الموقع
من الصعب جدا التقدم في خطوات عمليه في
تنفيذ الاتفاق هذه همم وهذه بناء صيغه
يحتاج لعمل مشترك يحتاج الى همم المضيف
النقاشات في بعض القضايا المؤجله في في
الاتفاق مثل غدايا اصلاح الاجهزه الامنيه
والعسكريه غدايا لتحقيق العداله اصلاح
مؤسسات عداله غدايا تفكيك النظام السابق
الغداء بتاعه الموقف من اتفاق جوبا للسلام
قضايا شرق السودان هذا ملف معقد لابد من
الوصول لاتفاق يحقق مشاركه شرق السودان
يحقق همم
خالد على هذا
ونتابع مع حضراتكم هذه اللقطات التي
وردتنا منذ قليل لزياره رئيس الروسيه
لجسر القرملي اول مرتين بعد حادث الانفجار
الذي وقع في اكتوبر الماضي في هذا الجسر
حينما عبرت سياره مفخخه هذا الجسر وادت
الى وقوع تفجير كبير به في ضربه وصفت
بانها ضربه عنيفه لروسيا لاعتبار ان هذا
الجسر هو حيوي للغايه وهو الاساسي الذي
يربط هذه المنطقه منطقه جسر القرمه التي
ضمتها روسيا
بالاراضي الروسيه نحن نشاهد بوتين وهو
يقوم بقياده هذه السياره
لا تبدو واضحه ولكن يبدو انه يقود هذه
السياره على جسر القرم نفسه
وبجانبه احد الاشخاص ولكن بوتين يقود هذه
السياره
بتجيبي تي كمان ما يتبخرش سوداء في جدار
فيه
ملف تحديدي سقف لسعر النفط الروسي ينضم
الينا من الثناء دكتور عبد اللطيف درويش
استاذ الاقتصاد واداره الازمات مرحبا بك
دكتور هناك حاله من الترقب لتداعيات تحديد
سعر او سقف لسعر النفط الروسيه روسيا تقلل
من الامر والاطراف الغربيه تقول انه امر
جيد سيكون عقوبه كبيره لروسيا ومنذ قليل
البيت الابيض قال ان رئيس بيض يقول انه
سيتم الافراج عن بعض مخزون النفط بعد
تطبيق هذا السعر ما الذي يمكن ان يحمله
هذا العنوان العريض
تحياتي لكم المشاهدين اولا انا لا في رايي
انا لا زلت المبادره في موضوع
الغاز او النفط لازلت في يد روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي ليس في هذه المبادره
الاجراءات بدات على اساس قطع تماما
العلاقات الطاقه مع روسيا من النفط والغاز
ولكنها
اريد فقط
استيراد النفط الروسي من قبل فقط الهند 25
ضعف
وكذلك بالنسبه للصين فالحين يتجد روسيا
حلول لنطقها في الوقت الذي لا توجد بدائل
لدى الاتحاد الاوروبي هو العديد
لان الكل يترقب موقف الصين حتى اللحظه
هناك عقود كما ذكرت حضرتك من الهند ومن
تركيا لكن حتى اللحظه ليس هناك رد فعل
رسمي او واضح من الصين هل لديك معلومات
مختلفه عن هذا الانطباع
قبل قليل
ستستمر في استراد النفط الروسي حسب العقود
وحسب الاتفاقيات مع روسيا فهذه بدائل جيده
اذا استطاعت روسيا فقط وقت يعني بيع النفط
لاسبوع فستخلق حائل للغليان وارتفاع في
اسعار النفط في الاسواق العالميه خاصه وان
الاوبك لم تاخذ منح الحرب ضد روسيا في هذه
الجوله
86$ يعني حدث بالفعل وهناك مخاوف من هذا
الامر في ظل تباته انمو العالميه من جهه
وارتفاع اسعار الفائده من ناحيه اخرى
يعني هذا فقط في مجرد تصريحات من قبل
الاطراف واعلنت روسيا انها ستوقف بيع
النفط لاي دوله تلتزم بهذه الاسعار
ستكون خطيره على روسيا لا اعرف اذا كان
يسمعني ام لا يبدون الخط قد انقطع دكتور
عبد اللطيف درويش استاذ الاقتصاد وادارات
الازمات شكرا لك
ونبقى معكم في سباق الخامسه من العربيه
ولدينا
بركان مانويل يواصلوا ثورانه بعد ثبات
طويل دم 38 عاما
اهلا بكم الى الخميس من جديد الى ملف
الاحتجاجات المتواصله في ايران فقد اغلقت
محلات تجاريه ابوابها في عده مدن ايرانيه
في اطار اضراب عام لمده ثلاثه ايام ابتداء
من اليوم وفي طهران تظهر مقاطع الفيديو
وان الباعه في عده اسواق اضربوا عن العمل
وابقى ومحلهم مغلقه ووفقا لمجلس تنسيق
الاحتجاجات انضم عمال عقود النفط في ايران
للاضراب ويستمر طلاب الجامعات في شتى
المدن الايرانيه في اضرابهم الذي بدا مع
انطلاق الاحتجاجات كما اعربت مجموعه من
الفنانين والرياضيين عن تضامنها مع
الاضطرابات العامه واعلنت انها لن تمارس
انشطه في هذه الايام الثلاثه
هذا وافادت وكاله تسنيم الايرانيه للانباء
ان الحرس الثوري الايراني قال ان قوه
الامن لن ترحم من وصفتهم بمثير الشغب
وقطاع الطرق والارهابيين كما اشاد الحرس
الثوري بالقضاء الايرانيه لموقفه من
الاحتجاجات وحتى هو على الاصراع في اصدار
الاحكام بحق المتهمين بارتكاب ما وصفته
بجرائم ضد امن الوطن والاسلام
والى محور المهم لاختراق السبراني نوع من
انواع المقاومه في ايران شكلتها مجموعه
الهاكرز بلاكرورد لاختراق جدار الغموض
السميك للنظام الايراني في وقت تشهد
البلاد اضطرابات واسعه ملاحظه للحكومه فل
الوقت الذي تشدد الصهران عمليات القمع
المتظاهرين اصبحت تسريبات والفضائح سلاح
القتال المدني الجديد قراصنه بلاك ورد
ازاحه الستاره عن معلومات دقيقه وحساسه
للغايه تتعلق بالاحتجاجات حصلوا عليها من
خلال سلسله من تسجيلات الصوت المسربه
ابرزها اعتراف لاميم سر مجلس ائتلاف قوه
ثوره رضا دوري في اجتماع مع كبار
المسؤولين الايرانيين حيث اقر بان الهجوم
على المدنيين الذي وقع في الثلاثين من
سبتمبر في مدينه زهدان عاصمه روشستان كان
خطا فادحا حسب وصفه
هذا واعتبرت برلين ان الغاء شرطه الاخلاق
في ايران لن يؤثر على تعبئه الايرانيين من
اجل حقوقهم الاساسيه وقالت ناطقه باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الالمانيه ان الايرانيين
ينزلون الى الشارع للدفاع عن حقوقهم
الاساسيه وانهم يريدون العيش بحريه
واستقلاليه مجدده على ان هذا الاجراء في
حاله تطبيقه لن يغير هذا الامر اطلاقا حسب
قولهم
وقبل ان نكمل بالملف الايراني نعود الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا ونعرض لحضراتكم هذه
الصور المتداوله لانفجارات جراء القصر
الروسي على اوكرانيا والذي اشار لها مراس
العربيه في بدايه هذه النشره
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات في ايران امين عام مركز مناهضه
العنصريه في ايران والباحث في الشان
الايراني يوسف عزيزي مرحبا بك يا سيد يوسف
دعني بدايه اتذكر شكل الخريطه الخاصه
بالاضرابات والاحتجاجات اليوم في ايران
تبدو الخريطه بالكامل باللون الاحمر وهذا
يشير الى الساعه هذه الاضرابات بشكل كبير
كيف يستطيع النظام ان يتعامل مع تحدي من
هذا النوع
اهلا وسهلا بكم وتحياتي لمشاهديكم الكرام
النظام في الواقع
لا يمكن ان يتحدى هذه الاضرابات وهذه
الانتفاضه الثوريه
المستمره نحو 80 يوما لماذا هو لذلك لان
وكماشرتم انتم الى التسجيلات المسربه من
الجلسات السريه والاجتماعات السريه
وقاده الحرس ومسؤولين اخرين ايه اكدت لنا
ووضحت لنا امور كثيره ومنها اضرابات
يوم 15 نوفمبر اضرابات اللي عمت اسواق همم
طهران او البازارات في طهران والمدن
الاخرى وكنا معظم الاعلام ال- ال- الفارسي
في الخارج كان يتصور انه بعض عشر او 15
مدينه بس لكن ما تسرب اكد ان هناك 22
محافظه 22 محافظه في 15 نوفمبر اصغر
النظام الايرانيه مع هذه التطورات سواء من
حيث اتساع حجم الاضرابات او من حيث توثيق
الجرائم المرتكبه من قمع من قبل قوات
الامن الايرانيه
لحد اللحظه لا يعرف وسيله واداه الا العنف
والغمغ
والكذب والخداع يعني همم حتى هذه الموضوع
اللي اشدته عنه يعني موضوع يعني
وقف عمل همم شرطه الاخلاق هذا ايضا ليس
مؤكدا همم في صرح به المدعي العام ونفاهه
مسؤول اخر
مره
اعدمه ثلاثه من المتظاهرين
المتظاهرين والمحتاجين من لندن مركز
ملاحظه العنصريه في ايران وال واحد في
الشان الايراني يوسف عزيزي تحياتي واعتذر
لضيق الوقت
وفي هذا السياق اغلقت ايران متجرا لبيع
المجوهرات ومطعم تابعين للاعبي كره القدم
على دقائق بعد ان ايد دعوات المحتاجين
لتنظيم اضرابات هذا الاسبوع وذلك وفقا
لماذا ذكرته وسائل الاعلام المحليه وذكرت
ايضا وكالات اخبار عده نقلا عن المركز
الاعلامي التابع للسلطه القضائيه ان اوامر
صدرت باقى متجر ومطعم اللاعب السابقين في
احدى مناطق سهران الرقيقه قال اللاعب
الاسبوع الماضي انه استهدف بتهديدات بعد
ما اعلن دعمه لاحتجاجات التي اثارتها وفاه
مهدي امين
وهتشتغل منافسات المونديال والتفاصيل دوما
في مجازنا الرياضي مع زميلي محمد القناص
اليك محمد
[موسيقى]
رياض حياكم الله تخطى المنتخب الانجليزي
عقبه السنغال نحو دور الربع النهائي
بالفوز بثلاثه اهداف دون رد ليضرب موعد مع
المنتخب الفرنسي في قمه مثيره مرتبه
الانجليزي الاول عبر لاعب الوسط الهندي في
الدقيقه 88 من عمر الشوط الاول بيحتفل
باول اهدافه في كاس العالم قبل ان يفك
اخيرا
صيامه عن التهديد في هذه النسخه من
المونديال ويسجل الهدف الشخصيه الاول في
المسابقه والهدف الثاني من المنتخب البلاد
هذه في مرمى السنغال
ومنح بوكايو ساكا بلاده الهدف الثالث عند
الدقيقه الثامنه والخمسين
يؤكدتهم في التاهل الى ربع النهائي
[تصفيق]
لقيت راسه تلاقي فرنسا التي قادها النجم
كلين بابيل العبور الى الدور ربع النهائي
بعد ما سجل هدفين في شباكه بولندا في
مباراه انتهت بثلاثه اهداف لهدف ونجح
اوليفيجرو بتسجيل الهدف الاول لمنتخب
فرنسا في الدقيقه الرابعه والاربعين والذي
اصبح به الهداف التاريخي للمنتخب الفرنسي
برصيد 52 هدفا منتخب
الثالث الاول جاء في دقه الرابعه والسبعين
الثاني جاء في الدقيقه 90 واسد روبير
جزاء في الوقت المحتسب بدلا من الله في
المباراه
وينتقي منتخب اليابان ونظيره الكرواتي ضمن
منافساتي دور 16 من مسافه من منافسات كاس
العالم لكره القدم خلقه الساموراي
المفاجاه بتصدر المجموعه امام المنتخبات
كبيره مثل اسبانيا والمانيا من جانبه فان
وصيفه نسخه الماضيه في المونديال وصل
ثانيا في المجموعه التي تصدرها المنتخب
المغربي هي المجموعه السادسه
هذه المره الثالثه التي يلتقي فيها وصيف
بطل العالم المنتخب الكرواتي بنظيره
الياباني في تاريخ النهائيات في فرنسا عام
98 كانت المواجهه الاولى بين المنتخبين
بدور المجموعات وانتهت بهدف اليتيم لصالح
رفاق دافور شوكر قبل ان تتكرر بعد ثمان
سنوات في المانيا وبدوري المجموعات كذلك
وانتهت بالتعادل بلا اهداف
الموعد الثالث بين المنتخب
واسبانيا جعلها تصل الى ثمن النهائي
بمعنويه اكبر بحث عن انجاز تاريخيه بعد ان
خرجت منه في ثلاث سنين سابقه
كرواتيا بقياده مدربها زلاتكو داليتشو
وخبره الثلاثي مودريتش وكرامه ريتش
وبيريزيج بلغت الثمن النهائي دون ان تقنع
في دوري المجموعات واليابان تالقت وابدعت
وخلفت كل التوقعات
اليوم لتجنب المفاجات عندما تلتقي كوريا
الجنوبيه كان المنتخب البرازيلي تعرض
لهزيمه المفاجاه امام الكاميرا في الجوله
الثالثه من دوري المجموعات بينما تاهلت
كوريا الى الادوار الاقصائيه بعد انتصار
الهام وحاسم امام المنتخب البرتغال بهدفين
لهذا هذه المباراه هي الاولى بين المنتخب
منتخب كوريا الجنوبيه يصل الى مرحله خروج
المغلوب للمره الثالثه بعد ست مشاركات 4
نقاطا جمع الكوري واحتل بها وصفات
المجموعه الثامنه بفارق نقطتين عن منتخب
البرتغال
بعد خبر التاهل كانت دموع سون هي الحدث
الابرز في كوريا كسب بها تعاطف الجماهير
سون الذي يضع على عاتقه حمل امل المنتخب
بلاده تعدى مرحله كونه نجما في ملاعب
واصبح رمزا في كوريا والجماهير تنتظر منه
التالق امام السامبا تماما مثل ما يفعل في
انجلترا
منتخب البرازيل هذه المره هو مرشح فوق
العاده لاضافه النجمه السادسه الى قميصه
لكن الهزيمه امام الكاميرون دقت ناقوس
الخطر في معسكر السامبا كتيبه تيتي وصلت
الى الادوار الاقصائيه وهي مثقله
بالاصابات جيسوس وتيليس لن يكون متاحين
فيما تبقى من البطوله وحاله من الشك تحوم
حول جاهزيه الظهيره الاساسيه
وتطيح باحد الكبار في هذا الدور ام ستثبت
البرازيل بانها قادمه لتتويج بالكاس
الثانيه لها في القاره الصفراء
الظهور القويه لوسود الاطلس جذب اهتمام
الصحف الاسبانيه انجازا يتكرروا للمره
الثانيه لكن ليس من صداره المجموعه فهل
يتغلب المنتخب المغربي على نفسه في هذه
النسخه
المغرب يدخل دوره 16 للمرات الثانيه في
تاريخه وبمعنويات عاليه بعد تصدر المجموعه
السادسه
[تصفيق]
الاهتمام الصحف الاسبانيه فصحيفه البايظ
ذكرت ان المغرب يقف في تاريخ اسبانيا
ووصفته بكونه افضل جيد في تاريخ الكره
المغربيه
ويعتبر المنتخب الذي يقوده لويس انريكا
الاكثر استحوادا على الكره من بين
المنتخبات المتاهله لدور 16 بنسبه تصل الى
75% فيما الاسود وبمباريه الثلاث
المجموعات لم يتفوق على اي منتخب في
الاستحواذ على الكره الا انه كان الاكثر
تسديدا على المرمى من منافسه
ويشهد معسكر المنتخب المغربي بعد الاصابات
عبرزه لاشرف حكيمي عز الدين مناحي لكنه
مشاركتهما امام العروخا والده
ويلقى وليد الرجراجي الثناء بعد المستويات
الكبيره لزملائي حكيم زياش وذلك رغم وصوله
قبل ثلاثه اشهر من انطلاق المونديال وهو
الذي اصبح اول مدرب عربي يقود منتخب بلاده
لدور 16 في العرس العالمي
[موسيقى]
كذلك رشا
شكرا جميله محمد قناص ورصد الاجواء قبل
بدايه مباراه اليابان وكرواتيا معنا من
الدوحه العربيه ليث البداري مرحبا بك لايف
كنت بالامس تحمل ديك الفرنسي وانتصرت
فرنسا
بمباراه ممتعه للغايه وكان امبابي خيالي
في الحقيقه ولكن اسيا اليوم حاضره وبقوه
كوريا الجنوبيه لديها مباراه مع البرازيل
وايضا اليابان لديها مباراه مع كرواتيا
اسيا تتصدر هذا المشهد من المونديال كيف
تبدو الاجواء لديك
اليوم رشا ما لبست ولا لون اي بلد مشان
نكون محايدين من شان نبين انه ما يحصل هو
مش بنشجعه على كل حال الحكايه قبل شويه
لزميل محمد القناص انه برازيل خايفين من
كوريا الجنوبيه صحيح فهو اليوم الثالث من
تصفيات الربع النهائي في مونديال قطر 2022
وستكون المنافسه الاسيويه الاوروبيه
اللاتينيه بين البرازيل طبعا التي ستلعب
ضد كوريا الجنوبيه في ستاد 94
واليابان ضد كرواتيا على ارض ملعب الجنوب
هنا في قطر المنتخب البرازيلي رشا بطل
العالم خمس مرات يطمح بمواصله حلمه نحو
استعاده لقب كاس العالم الغائب عن خزائن
هذا المنتخب منذ 20 عاما اليوم وصل الى
ثمن النهائي في قطر 2022 ويسعى البرازيلي
اكتشفت البرازيل
ما بحب يطلع ع الكره شفتي
لتصريحات همم المدرب سيلعب المدرب
البرازيلي قال ان نيمار سيلعب اليوم الى
اي مدى اثر ذلك في معنويات البرازيليين
يتدرب النجم البرازيلي نيمار مع منتخب
البرازيل مره اخرى رجع ويوم السبت
فيما تم استبعاد الظهير الايسر الاكستليس
والمهاجم غابرييل جيسوس همم يعني لم تبقى
همم من المباريات كاس العالم الى القليل
قربنا على النهائي تقريبا بعد طبعا
اصابتهما في المباراه ضد المنتخب
الكاميرون وقال اطباء منتخب البرازيل انهم
سيعيدهم تقييم اصابه نيمار قيموها بعد ظهر
اليوم وسوف يلعب خلص التدريبات وسيقررون
او قرروا وخلصوا انه يعني قادر متاح
بين اليابان وكرواتيا وهناك تحويل كبير
على منتخب اليابان في هذا المونديال كيف
تبدو اجواء هذه المباراه ايضا
المباراه هاي احنا مش راح نحضرها بس ولكن
تكلمت مع بعض المشجع بعض المشجعين الكثير
منهم الفاجاء لي انهم اوروبيون هنا يشجعون
فريق الفريق الياباني يعني اللي شفنا من
اللي شفناه في المباريات من اداء الفريق
الياباني هذا قد يعني ليش ما يصير همم
نتوقع يكون هناك نجاح اكبر المنتخب
الياباني على كل حاسه ترتفع مشاركه اسيا
وافريقيا في المونديال المقبل عام 2026 مع
رافعه مع مع رفعه هذه البرازيل وكوريا
الجنوبيه
فقط زميلي ليس بازاري
طعامه سنكون معكم بالنشرات اكيد من
المشجعين ال- البرازيليين شكرا
لكوريين الجنوبيون اكيد
بعد وصولهم الى الارض سلم رواد الفضاء من
الصين اكاديميه العلوم النباتات وعينات
النباتيه جلبوها معهم وذلك في اطار تجارب
تجريها الصين لزراعه في الفضاء ويقول
العلماء ان زراعه الارز تتقدم بثلاثه
[موسيقى]
بعد ان ضل في سبات طويله دم 38 عاما يوصل
بركان ماللوفي جزر هاواي ثورانه وينشر
البركان حممه ونوافير اللهب لليوم الخامس
على التوالي ويعدها هذا البركان اكبر
بركان الناشط في العالم
الطبيعه وصلنا لختام الخامسه من العربيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]